[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared here in the flesh
this time you guys may or may not know
this but wisecrack Editions take a
really long time and we've been wanting
to do something where we can quickly
react to what's currently on TV or in
theaters so we because we try it out
with season three of Rick and Morty and
hey if you like this let us know we'd
love to do these on things like Game of
Thrones stranger things
whoever this Jake Paul person is you
name it in Rick dancing the stone we see
Rick summer and morty traversing a Mad
Max inspired post apocalypse what struck
me most about this episode was an idea
that has popped up in previous episodes
but hasn't been as fleshed out as fan
favorites like existence as pain and
everything you believe is both
scientifically traditions are an idiot
thing that idea modern alienation
through a bright glowing Rock a
mustachioed murderer and Jerry the
episode explores another depressing is
idea that society may be slowly
destroying our souls welcome Liz
wisecrack quick take on Rick man seing
the stone and of course spoilers ahead
but first a quick recap
Rick Morty and summer infiltrate the
aptly named death stalkers to steal a
glowing rock that Rick wants for science
Morty and summer used this aggressive
world to ven's all their confused
emotions about their parents divorce
summer does all kinds of acting out then
falls for a swole dude with a bucket on
his head and eventually goes through her
own divorce allowing her to
contextualise her parents separation
more defenses frustration by living
vicariously through a revenge driven arm
and eventually realizes he should just
let it go maybe the lesson we've learned
is that whether it's our parents
marriage a glowing green rock or an
awesome giant arm sooner or later you
gotta let it go
and Rick acts like a child kind of my
daughter's going through a divorce and I
am NOT dealing with it in a healthy way
at all early in the episode we hear Rick
introduced the idea of alienation but if
you're really that alienated I'm is
willing to exploit it as the next guy
Church Army or Olympic gymnastics
trainer suggesting that summers tension
with Jerry has made her disillusioned
and the only thing that can make her
feel alive is to travel to a place where
civilization has
now the clever thing here is that the
show not only tackles alienation on a
micro-level
the family kind that summer and more the
experience but on a macro level the
alienation of society as a whole and
through this the show frames how we lose
agency in our everyday lives
case in point Jerry I think this quote
informs a lot of what's going on in this
episode to live is to risk it all
otherwise you're just an inert chunk of
randomly assembled molecules drifting
wherever the universe blows you I'm
sorry Jerry I didn't see you there how
much of that did you hear what Rick is
not so subtly suggesting is Jerry's
complete and utter lack of personal
resolve power agency whatever you want
to call it
he's a doormat to the world this idea of
powerlessness informs a lot of Morty's
resentment towards Jerry as evidenced by
this and this
I think if dad really wanted to be here
he'd stop at nothing to make that happen
you know maybe dad just doesn't want you
back or maybe he just doesn't have the
strength to fight and in either case
he's got his life I got mine but Morty's
bitterness goes much further than
Jerry's failed marriage and it's because
in some ways Jerry is the everyman of
the modern world since the days of the
Industrial Revolution people have been
complaining about loss of control in the
modern world instead of having our own
trade or farm any toilet at monotonous
jobs this loss of autonomy is reflected
on by countless authors scholars and
films but we might as well just throw
this example at you see all this
potential message Flom goddamnit an
entire generation pumping gas waiting
tables slaves with white collars
advertising has us chasing cars and
clothes working jobs we hate we don't
need the middle children of history man
and this is what frames Marty's anger at
Jerry's powerlessness Jerry is the
pinnacle of modern stew Jerry his
existence as a cog in a meaningless
machine is
driven home in the Rick shank redemption
where the Galactic Federation keeps
everyone compliant and docile through a
liberal use of pharmaceuticals a
Galactic Federation taking over earth
the best thing that's ever happened to
this family I just got my six promotion
this week and I still don't know what I
do
in other words Jerry is so bad at being
a person he thrives in a society devoid
of freedom
some are show your father some respect
he's pulling down a six chewable figure
income his inability to assert himself
is put on display in every interaction
he has with Rick of course there is a
version of Jerry who isn't in Rick's
words an inert chunk of randomly
assembled molecules drifting wherever
the universe blows and that would be
Jerry from Cronenberg when stripped of
the trappings of modern society Jerry
goes from being a useless hack and a
loveless marriage to a total badass who
seems to be keeping his marriage
together
this in itself is hilarious but with
this latest episode I think Rick and
more use playing with this idea that the
trappings of modern society are
inherently alienating and create Jerry's
out of all of us after Rick introduces
electricity to the wasteland it soon
resembles a modern industrialized
Society summers violent lifestyle has
been traded in for everyday finalities
she isn't out murdering mutants
she's grocery shopping for human bits
the savagery of the death stalkers has
been reduced to complaining about
recycling and hemorrhage the murdering
machine is now a good-for-nothing couch
potato you haven't moved since I left to
scavenge this morning
what's so clever here is the implication
that modern comforts are what drive our
banal terrible lives with no mutants to
fend off people resort to bickering
about trivialities we notice that you've
been put in scrap metal in the blue bag
I got it due to electricity people
aren't murdering each other in the blood
dome they're watching blood dome see
most post-apocalyptic fiction functions
as a cautionary tale of how awful our
lives might become but of course being
the darkest show on
Rick and Morty goes out of its way to
prove that modern life is its own
special brand of soul crushing our
comforts eventually alienate us from
meaning creating different kinds of
misery or as Rick says about ruining
summers marriage grandpa just sped
things up with a few creature comforts
of modern society so here's an
interesting question that's a bit
speculative but the summer forgive her
father because she sees that
modernization turns every man into an
action list lump even if you're a
post-apocalyptic badass now I want to
speculate a little bit about Jerry here
it's likely that Rick will stay the same
old uncaring ass he's ever been but I
think we're gonna see a lot of character
growth in his family members
specifically Jerry what if he has a
Tyler Durden moment would be Cronenberg
Jerry what if he like Edward Norton goes
from being a disaffected modern buffoon
to a man of passion I mean the show has
countless references to popular cinema
and I think a Fight Club shout-out would
work perfect for Jerry's season three
arc but hey I guess we're just gonna
have to see as season 3 continues thanks
a lot for watching guys if you want to
hear more about this week's Rick and
Morty episode we actually just released
the first episode of the wise track
podcast where we talk all about you
guessed it Rick and Morty so click the
link in the description to check out our
podcast and let us know what you think
we've got more Rick and Morty stuff
coming out so make sure to subscribe
watch all later peace
[Music]